[Applaudissements]
cette année j'ai offert la l'abonnement
à femme actuelle
[Applaudissements]
cette année cette nuit j'ai rêvé que je
m'étais fait choper par un singe pour le
spectacle il partage le film il est
servi c'est ce qu'ils vont faire comme
si beaucoup de neige
les chevaliers du mondial noël d'enfer
les chevaliers du fiel vous souhaite une
bonne année et wayne on n'a pas ça merci
demande à voir
au jardin offre à mener pour tout le
monde mais non il n'y a pas pour tout le
monde a alors donné la donné en plus
méritants pour bouleverser
qu'est ce que vous faites isabelle je
fais la collection voilà j'aurai mal
j'irai pas une année là
[Applaudissements]